on this episode I talk about advice in
social media to parents blogging the
current state and changing your
business's name you ask questions and I
answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 83 on the ask gary vee
show I'm a fairly grumpy mood because
Stefan and I were on the basketball team
that lost two runs this morning
including the second game where we up
ten four in a game to fifteen and we
lost so let's do the show Thomas asked
hey Gary what is the future of vlogging
and all this rented social media space
you know Thomas I think the interesting
thing about blogs and and I and it's
really fascinating for me to watch
what's happening is in two thousand
three four five six
it was very commonplace to use the
Internet in a way where you would be
driving someone to your home right like
come here to consume me here I think
when we're seeing a lot now is I'm over
here if you want me to know what's up
you better learn how to speak to me here
and so I think that what's happened is
the attention graph that I spent so much
time paying attention to is shifting and
people's willingness to jump to
someplace to consume is not down because
the truth is I believe social networks
specifically Twitter and Facebook and
Pinterest
yeah those and LinkedIn are really
gateway drug pieces of content to drive
to this before-mentioned home a blog an
e-commerce site your your download page
to your app so you know I think what's
changed is people understanding they
need a great scale to be a wonderful
storyteller within social networks to
become a first impression to that you
know it's like you have to be really
good at the bar before you get a chance
to do something at home and I think
that's the analogy that I'm looking for
if you know what I mean John asked what
are your thoughts on creating a
successful long term social media
strategy for yourself or your clients
how long in advance do you create the
content you
John this is a good question I mean I
think this all comes down to something
that I call reverse engineering the
truth is everybody's different you know
my my vision is very long term I don't
know how you define long term and your
question but some people think long term
is three to five years I think long term
is until the day I die and so my clients
may not be as patient when you're a
fortune 500 company that needs to hit
numbers each quarter your patients to
build a three to five-year plan is
non-existent when you're a Series C
startup company that just raised two
hundred million dollars and you're only
burning four million dollars you've got
a lot of patients and the idea of
building brand and having a patient's
game to to your execution becomes more
attractive than we reverse engineer that
then it's more about branding Instagram
doing high-end video long-form content
with no right hook a lot of jabbing if
your startup that's gonna go out of
business in 24 weeks
if you don't sell some stuff we're in
full right hand hook you know Facebook
dark posts SEO SEM influencer marketing
with calls to action to sell you know
all that stuff completely is determined
based on the clients current short-term
and long-term needs but the truth is
short-term and long-term needs really
balance based on a moment in time and so
you know the reason I think I'm good at
business is for all of my talking I am
10x
at my listening skills and it all just
comes down to listening and and so the
way we strategize is predicated on
listening and and I think the biggest
challenge for so many of the
vaynernation that's that's watching
right now is I don't think a lot of you
and this is with all due respect this is
for everybody I'm just picking on you
because I love you tough love
I think a lot of people aren't really
sure what they want to accomplish in a
your window versus a five-year window
versus a ten-year window and their
behavior doesn't map to it you know to
me I got lucky I just decided it's
everybody shows up to my funeral
hedge forever build up equity cash it in
what as I need it if I ever need it
which has allowed me to be very patient
and and really has allowed me to dictate
my behavior of being probably a better
human being and in a weird way and again
I think a lot of people would find this
funny in a lot of ways I've been a
pushover as a as a entrepreneur because
if you would look at it in the
short-term
I'm leaving money on the table I'm not
fighting for every cent I'm not trying
to drill it down to the biggest
advantage I'm not even getting mine
every time because I'm just hedging
along the way and so it just comes down
to what you're trying to accomplish I
think the better question to this
question is how how can you help someone
or you capable of really understanding
what you're trying to accomplish
Matthew asked hey Gary I'm speaking to
parents at a public school event on
parenting in a social media world what
would you teach them every time I get in
front of parents they get really upset
with me because my move is to punch them
directly in the mouth parents are
becoming their parents on an everyday
basis I would tell them that they're
fearing technology and they're forcing
their kids to spend less time on it
which is not preparing them for the
actual world in the future I would tell
them that they talk about how much they
hate technology and its impact on kids
but they should look themselves in a
mirror because every time they won't
don't want a parent or the kids crying a
little bit more than they like they
throw an iPad at them like it's a
Chinese star III would tell them that
they're full of [ __ ] and hypocrites and
should never try to build their
self-esteem through their kids
accomplishments if your little Ricky's
the best baseball player in the 4th
grade team that has nothing to do with
you except it has your DNA but like
don't walk around like you're the best
player on the 4th grade team so you know
I I would tell them that it's never been
a better time to be a parent because all
the social networking tools allow us to
spire
our kids that know what they're doing at
a level never seen before I'm you know I
used to think it was great that I lived
in New York that I wouldn't have to
worry about drunk driving now no parent
does because by the time their kids are
the age
uber will be at scale I would tell them
to stop playing defense and stop being
scared and start playing offense and
start being pumped moving bezel asked we
are in a non-existent market but the
sharing economy is growing and we play
in there what would you do to determine
or come up with a market size moving
bezel you know you know obviously I'm
jam with you a little bit on social you
know I guess you're asking me this
question to try to figure out how to put
it into your deck so that you could
raise money you know the people are
gonna give you money are not going to
give you money on the potential market
size of the watch renting market they're
gonna do it because because you're right
it doesn't exist they're gonna do it
because they believe is you in you as a
entrepreneur hustler and they're gonna
believe in the sharing economy and
they're gonna think that watches are an
interest graph of end users but you know
I don't think you have to come up with
you know the amount of financial
engineering that goes on and startup
culture in the finance world and raising
capital is really silly to me what you
could do is you could find out how big
the air B&B market is then you can
figure out how big the renting market is
versus the overall watch market and then
you can just do the math and say okay
there's a lot of hacking you can do but
I think you're asking the wrong question
and I think India when you asked it
before we did the show I think wasn't
there also like how do you market to a
market that doesn't exist yet or
something you know I I do too and I
think and I think that you know I think
that I've spent a lot of time thinking
about that in general in my career and I
dislike it when people that are started
or businesses in it are asking that
question because obviously you've
started the business with a belief that
that markets gonna happen and more
importantly I think there's a confusion
to you about what you're actually
marketing to your thinking how do i
market to people to build awareness that
hey you can trade
rent and share watches the truth is
they're just watch enthusiasts and so
like their their marketing too you know
I think people get confused when they're
marketing a new version of a historical
product versus creating a new product
that doesn't exist
you know uber didn't have to sell that
like people rented black cars and took
taxis they had to bring some awareness
to they existed but don't think
anybody's confused that's listening and
watching right now or if anybody out
here like watches you know India there's
watches you can you can rent them and
you can put yours on there like just not
super complicated yeah just not
complicated and so you mark it to people
that give a crap about watches Andrew
asked my investor wants to change the
name of my company's brand Sasquatch
fuel should I change the name to
something I includes the name of our
unique pouch-like Omni field Andrew I
think a lot of people that are watching
this show we're gonna say he's about to
go crazy I mean like screw your
investors stick to your guns
truth is I'm a very funny guy when it
comes to names
I think execution is everything and I
think the name is literally irrelevant
like you know what did Google mean to
anybody before
you know it became something what did
the word Nike mean to anybody before
Nike made it happen like my last name is
a Vaynerchuk you know like face to teach
you in Hollywood before you build a
brand like I would have been Gary Smith
you know in in 1961 if I went to
Hollywood and did this like names don't
mean crap what you make that name mean
is the real game and so you know you
want to be a pushover I'm just kidding
you want to you want to change your name
great you want like you don't want to
change your name great look bottom line
is is your product good are you gonna be
able to to mark it I mean you know
what's the other name that he's
considering changing it to yeah i like
sasquatch better not me something i
remember better omni you like
everything's on me and so and so yeah
that's it
it's all got question of the day are you
so competitive that if you lose a
meaningful basketball game in the
morning
would you allow it to completely alter
the happiness in your day you give
asking questions I'll keep answering
them you can see the fika monsters gonna
come up here and be like don't give me
press indie rock
you